if i worked on a terrestrial company i
would know what regulations i operate
under a terrestrial company
you have to say that now terrestrial
company
[Music]
welcome to star talk everyone this is
star talk recording live
at a space sustainability summit in
london
[Applause]
this will be an entire program devoted
to space sustainability and this is
nothing i can do on my own first i got
to bring in my co-host which is part of
the dna of start talk a professional
stand-up comedian and who do we have
here matt come on up matt
matt
yes
not winning uh i yeah pleasure to be
with you here yeah yeah come on come on
yeah um it's good to be in london a city
that um you can't ever see any stars in
so i've
missed most of them my entire life all
right so matt is also uh
he's not only a professional stand-up
comedian from scotland
yeah scotland uh he's also uh an expert
in environmental causes
and in fact your your let me get your
full your full uh cv description here
environmental research fellow yeah at
university college in london yeah thanks
exactly and you've written a book on
this subject yep
it's a comedy book
hot mess yeah hot mess what on earth can
we do about climate change that is the
name of the book you birthed this during
covington i did i sat in a room for a
year while i had us
like a baby i don't know if you've heard
of him yeah i had a baby
and and there was covert so i couldn't
leave the house and i sat in a room and
wrote a book about uh i think the
world's first comedy book about climate
change
we'll find out uh where that goes in a
moment
let me introduce our our
aerospace engineer panelists okay uh
first up
we've got
jenna tawan jenna come
jen is an on engineer and you're also
uh head of business development for
ispace not head yet oh
i'm not headed yes okay i love it loving
it there
business development so you have an
aerospace background engineering
background but also some business jobs
right so this is with uh ispace yeah a
japanese company and they do what what's
their one sentence is a lunar
exploration company um
headquartered in tokyo but has european
and american offices
um and really we have a have a view to
connect the moon and the earth as an
ecosystem and i will leave it at that
for now
beyond where we are now worried about
low earth orbit and other places like
that
we'll come back to you okay have a seat
and we also have danielle wood an
aerospace engineer from mit daniel
welcome
[Applause]
assistant professor of aerospace
engineering at mit and also director of
mit space enabled program we'll ask more
about that as we come along here
pleasure to be here with you all
okay we will also thank our sponsors
which include for this broadcast i want
to thank privateer space uh for this and
of which we just heard from mora baja
and also of course omega watches
some of you may or may not know omega
was the first watch on the moon in the
apollo program
and they earned that spot as i
understand it they did an experiment
where they bought all the fancy
expensive swiss watches and put them in
a black box and shake them and bake them
and and accelerated them and
and checked at the end they opened the
boxes he still kept time and omega did
it best
so as i understand it omega earned that
place in the history of space
exploration we thank publicly thank
omega for this
[Applause]
what time it is on the moon what's the
time zone oh
yeah i don't know it's time zone is
houston time oh yeah
that makes sense yeah of course of
course this huge time all over the moon
so i'd like to begin this program with a
a five-minute clip of a conversation i
had
with steve wozniak
okay you may have heard of him uh he
co-founded a company that and we're
gonna make oranges and they changed it
and they
decided instead to make apples
so steve wozniak and steve jobs
co-founders of apple computer why do i
have this conversation with steve
wozniak because
he is active in this space
see what i did there
he cares about space sustainability he
uh uh
and in fact he's one of the founding
members of privateer so let's join us in
that clip with steve wozniak
you're engaged in this enterprise called
privateer
which is all about space but when people
think about space we think okay who's
what rocket are you launching and is it
going to be suborbital or orbital are
you going to go to mars are you going to
terraform and none of that is on your is
in your portfolio so could you please
explain to me
what are you doing in space that no one
else is doing first of all you know i
like yourself get you know dozen pitches
a day join our operation our company
lend your name to it whatever and it's
just i'm only one person i do not live
in a big like kind of i have a team
world and all that i'm a company so i
take on very very few of these and this
one was one i took on largely because of
my total most respect for my best friend
alex fielding's our ceo what we started
up for was based around um alex myself
and moripa jaw a professor at ut austin
he has been an environmentalist about
space and he has been so concerned about
you know what's going on and where we're
going in space and especially this idea
of junk and we want to be starting out
it's like you've got to know what's
there before you can deal with anything
and we want to be a good mapping
organization but we want more than that
we want to form standards and
interoperate with other people that have
satellites up in space that have good
useful information for those of us on
earth and we want to share it and sort
of have um the standard ways of
representing you know where things are
and you first of all you've got to know
where things are to avoid collisions is
what you're doing then creating
a a landscape i really should call it a
spacescape
am i allowed is that such a does that
word exist yet uh the the natural
evolution of a landscape would be a
spacecape you're creating a spacescape
on which future participants in space
can make intelligent decisions
collaboratively if necessary
so that everyone can play in the same
sandbox that is exact that's a very good
way to say it yes exactly well this
would this word sustainability which is
a buzzword today in so many sectors
we've never heard it used before with
regard to space could you tell me what
that means in space well you know it's
things are growing out of control out of
regulation and what's going up uh it's
growing exponentially the number of
launches the number of of things that
we're putting up in especially near
orbit near earth orbit and we just want
to you know have a an environment where
it doesn't become too dangerous to
launch the satellites that are so key to
our humanness well i in some ways it's
kind of a happy problem to have because
it's saying i mean when you consider 60
years ago there was one satellite in
orbit or two and now we have countless
thousands accountable thousands but the
fact that within 16 years is like
look what we got from that look what we
got from that all of silicon valley i
was fortunate to live there and we had a
space race going on and the space race
lockheed martin moved into sunnyvale and
intel started up in santa clara and the
need for chips
low it was so every gram cost so much
money to launch into space back in those
days that oh my gosh if you could make
six transistors on one little piece of
silicon instead of one piece six times
less the weight and so we a lot of great
things that humans have now including
our entire digital world really grew out
of that effort to um to basically get
into space so yeah was that's a very
under appreciated fact about modern
technology and how
you know if it if it only ever stayed in
your living room why make it any smaller
than the furniture that was your radio
from the 1930s right if someone says i
want to put this technology in space oh
my gosh silicon valley get to work well
what i'm delighted to learn not only
about privateer but that you and your
ambitions and your following which is
huge and your legacy are all being
offered to this mission statement and
uh you are here at the beginning
of something that i'd like to think
um will be properly regulated going
forward so that space won't be a scary
place to visit it should be a delight
that for myself
i i would not risk my legacy of doing a
lot of good things
you know in my life would not risk it on
you know company that wasn't thinking
the same way
danielle let me come to you given to
your professional profile what does
sustainability mean to you
because we know at least from
terrestrial sustainability with the
environment everyone has sort of a
different sense of what that means i
just want to make sure we don't have to
be on the same page we just want to know
what pages are there in this business
in this playbook of sustainability
thanks so much now
we are in an important era in human
relationship to space humans are having
an ability now to use technology in a
way that's letting us influence what
happens in the space environment in ways
we've never seen before part of that is
the number of physical objects we put in
space and part of it is the way we
change the environment whether it's in
orbit around the earth or on the moon so
you can think about historically and
think about the number of objects we put
in space and also what happens at the
end of the mission of a satellite my
first training is in satellite design so
as a satellite designer as an aerospace
engineer at nyt no one asked me make
sure the end of the mission of this
satellite that you take care to throw
out your trash they just said make it
work but space sustainability means that
as satellite designers and operators and
regulators we check to see that at the
end of the operational use of a
satellite to monitor the weather or to
make sure we have communication systems
that we make sure that the next
generation of satellites and those in
many years to come can still come so
space sustainability means ensuring that
we can keep space a safe operational
place for many generations
that makes so much sense
did no one think about that for 50 years
let's just make a satellite and just
when it stops working doesn't leave it
there i mean who's thinking that why
well there's some physics to keep in
mind a couple of good things so one if
you work on a satellite let's think
about where the space station is about
400 kilometers or 250 miles above the
earth if you drop a satellite from there
which sometimes people do it's not going
to be in space too long fortunately
because there is a nice system where
there's a convenient set of
particles that are on top of the
atmosphere air molecules some molecules
some are ionized because some of them
have come apart and so we've got your
charged particles get your molecules
okay you've got a whole portfolio yes
these particles can provide some
friction if you're low enough in you
know in the altitude but as you go
higher and higher you know you have uh
less and less you have to move into a
true you know vacuum so that's the place
where you should what could you have
done
40 years ago
for a satellite that was above where you
have your air molecules and ionized
particles to slow it down and have it
re-enter this is a great question you
use this phrase slow it down the
question of deceleration right so one
question is are designers of satellites
being told you must ensure that you have
fuel that's going to give you the option
to deorbit are they happening this is a
good question it's not been required
i don't know if this happens
it's not useful to say you know that's a
good question where's the answer to that
right i'd say it's not happening enough
meaning there's been both uh either
regulations at the national level or
best practices saying it's important to
get your satellite out of space within
25 years now the question is is that
enforced by national governments and
also is other technical challenges make
it hard to do it so regulation is a
missing dimension here it's there but
needs to be changed and improved so matt
yeah your environment dude i'm i'm i'm a
very much down-to-earth sort of
environment dude okay and so
sustainability to you who thinks about
earth
problems what does it mean to you
i think it's to me sustainability is
kind of like gymnastics right in the
sense that it's very much about balance
and also i like doing it on my high
horse while wearing spandex
really not so much the spandex
but yeah it's it's
to me sustainability is basically just
thinking beyond today and yourself to
think about who's indirectly affected by
these things think about who's affected
by this
in space and time you know space and
time with that space in the earth or
space
and uh yeah so it's sort of long-term
thinking really
okay so that before i get back to you
here i just wanna he's talking about how
it affects different people
and that's so often a missing cog in a
wheel that we build and steer
right so
does
satellite
technology or the existence of
satellites affect different people
different ways on earth for my phd i
traveled to a number of countries in
africa as well as some teams in
middle east and southeast asia and i
asked people why does your country want
to have a space program and all over the
world everywhere i went every country
wants to have the ability to use
satellites for national mapping of the
environment making sure they can track
floods and reels after earthquakes
making sure they can have communications
as they need it and right now there's
not equal benefits in countries around
the world on how they use face
technology but it's possible to get
there especially if we keep asking you
know how countries are going to train
their next generation of engineers to
know how to design and operate
satellites so it's not just the
engineers at the table there's a
geopolitical dimension that needs
uh needs to be addressed
as well
uh okay so
what space does sustainability mean to
you oh one who sees to the moon beyond
all the seas to the moon
um
so it's i think it can span a lot of
things really um but sustainability
whether it is space whether it's
business
it's really about as matt said thinking
about the long-term mindset right so not
focusing on short-term gains at the
expense of your long-term
gains either so it's it's really you
know looking to the future and thinking
how you can do things with a longer-term
view
and one thing i want to mention is that
space by nature is not um homogeneous so
everyone's not going together there are
some countries that are really emerging
there are some companies that are you
know have been in space a lot longer and
so we our definition of sustainability
whatever that is needs to be sustainable
for yes the space frag nations now but
also the ones that are yet to come right
so some people are really at the
first early stages of their expanding
exciting space journey and we need to
make sure sustainability means for them
not only for the developed nations too
okay so
you're to do your job yeah you need
satellite data
satellites are so important to look at
climate change okay so
you're in a balancing point here because
you you want as many satellites as you
can get up there to help you on the
earth yet we're trying to regulate how
many there might ultimately be so is
there some implosion point
where okay
we have balanced this and we can't
lean left or right or forward or back
because the whole the whole system will
collapse maybe we'll get there we'll fix
the earth but space will be like yeah we
can't go there anymore
right but you can't fix the earth if you
don't have the satellite data to help
that exactly and too much sound and too
many satellites interferes with the
satellite environment chicken and egg
isn't it yeah
but yeah it's so important
the egg came first oh yeah yeah it was
laid by a bird that was not a chicken
we saw that problem
okay evolutionarily it was made by a
bird that you wouldn't have called a
chicken and then the egg hatches they
say that's a chicken so the egg came
first well what burnt
who cares she just said the bread
whatever burger was it was not a chicken
so that's interesting yeah yeah i didn't
yeah
chicken egg referencing there
the egg came first yes
great well i'm done
we've solved the big question
so so um tell me
about
so both of you and you you have a long
view by the way i'm totally impressed
with your dual background of aerospace
engineering and business yeah right
because without that
that other piece of this puzzle there is
no
meaningful
uh industry that you can
look to yeah and both sides need to talk
to each other and including lawyers and
including artists and really everyone
has some cool oranges yeah
sorry sorry sorry to mess that bubble
but a space sustainability conference i
think we need lawyers man
our space lawyers
there's a film there somewhere
um
see if they told me that in advance i
would have put a different joke in there
um
tell me more just take me
back to the moon and that sort of lunar
i guess this lunar space is involved
right the space between the earth and
the moon um is any are any solutions to
this problem available to us beyond the
three traditional earth orbits you know
leo mio and geo can we just dump garbage
on the moon or somewhere
i mean this is part of the problem
because technically right now we should
be mindful but there is nothing telling
you you can't and you know we shouldn't
and this is exactly why we need to talk
about it because with you know
with earth orbits we're at this point
where it's retrospective we're trying to
fix we know it's a problem at the moon
we're at the stage where we're not there
yet so we can do something about it now
you could prefix
problems that haven't originated yeah we
can be proactive rather than reactive
and that's very rare in the way you get
that instance to
play that role and be in this point of
time
um and so there should be more moon
discussions
okay when i think of the table that
people need to sit around to resolve
this as we go forward you know yes we
feel like a little bit behind the curve
but
we don't know how far it would go or
could go so maybe looking back on this
we're here at the right place at the
right time absolutely at the dawn of the
need for this kind of effort but when i
think who's at the table you're going to
have an uh earth environmentalist person
certainly we have business people
aerospace engineers satellite designers
the physics and the engineering of that
um is there someone else you think
should be at this table to
channel my geologist friends who would
tell me reason we want to dump a bunch
of trash on the moon is because the moon
is this beautiful pristine place where
there's not a heavy atmosphere a very
limited atmosphere so what we have is
this amazing record of when rocks come
through our solar system and like land
on the moon
the record is there forever it's so if
if we don't mess it up
if we don't don't follow our trash there
so no jumping trash on the moon we can
enjoy this record right it's all
history but what if you set up like a
recycling facility on the moon would
that be good i mean it's a business idea
yeah yeah no definitely and and this is
it right it's we need to be rather than
just one way of we're going and can't
survive the lunar night so hey ho on we
go we need to we we need to be able to
use what's up there to to create this
this kind of circular economy
and it's really difficult and no one's
cracked it but at least we're talking
about it yeah
so what about other cultures around the
world do they have seats at the table on
this you know i spent a long time during
the pandemic asking this question and
the chance like you wrote a book i had
conversations with indigenous scholars
and people who do research on
anti-colonial issues to ask the question
for those who have experienced something
anti-colonial
wow that's not that's a word
there's a whole scholarship
okay european colonization in two
sentences
is that yours that's mine now
your whole
museum
yeah so so what do they they can have
what would their seat at the table do
i sat and listened for hours and you can
join me because it's all available to
you online we recorded it we sat and
listened on zoom
to indigenous elders talk about the fact
that many cultures will start with those
in the north american region consider
not just the physical earth but also the
moon and parts of space as part of their
sacred heritage a place where they have
responsibility to care and there's an
interesting story it's a footstep but
also a lesson for us in the 1990s
we lost one of our astronomers
and somebody who we wanted to honor and
that nasa was interested
yes i'm just gonna have a mental
[Laughter]
thank you for finding my mistakes
excellent this is shoemaker so we lost
shoemaker uh nasa wanted to put the
ashes on the moon
oh eugene shoemaker yeah okay just a
quick background on him uh he was one of
the early geologists to identify that
the barringer crater in arizona was in
fact a meteoric origin this is a well
the perhaps the best preserved crater on
earth's surface for all the reasons
decided that
most craters earth would look like the
moon
were not for erosion and all the other
terrestrial forces that erase the
history of these collisions he was one
of the first to recognize that that was
an impact crater and in fact he was
slated to be the geologist to fly on
apollo 17 and i think they found some
kind of heart murmur with him and so
they sent another geologist instead but
he and his wife carolyn shoemaker and
david levy were big uh comet and
asteroid hunters and they've discovered
many many comets and asteroids but one
of them
they
gifted to me in my name so i actually
had an asteroid
one three one two three tyson discovered
by the shoemaker and levy uh perry so so
when he died they said let's send it boy
to the moon okay so is that what they
did they did and they did of course you
know there's a beautiful story that he
couldn't go personally and i'm sure he
was honored he missed out on the [ __ ]
right so because of that the family
really wanted to honor him so this was
done and it was done through a lander
but the interesting next step is done
through landing oh so it landed it so it
didn't um
smash into the moon no one of the goals
was for the ashes to be you know on a
safe mission but the next step of the
story
you want is answers to burn up they're
boring ashes
they were they're safely in turn okay
for the next step of the story is um a
public letter written by the president
of the navajo nation in the u.s whose
name's albert hale who says um we
understand this is you know done to
honor this important you know astronomer
and scientist but uh i wish that you had
asked for consultation on this because
many native communities in ours in
particular but others hold the moon as
sacred and objects that represent death
actually violate our understanding of
what's what's sacred on the moon i want
to give appreciation to a student of
mine named alvin harvey who's also from
the navajo nation who's done studies on
this and given me the knowledge i have
about it but just to say that it's a
conversation worth having to say if
there's cultural differences in how we
view what it means to honor someone in
the moon at least doing it publicly is a
great way to start so this is the
opposite of colonialism
the office of colonialism is actually
asking people what they care about and
value
and then
okay interesting so
uh let me not speak for them but speak
for what i think they might i don't
think it even occurred to them to ask i
don't see it as something malicious that
they did it just we need people such as
yourself to open that dialogue and
sensitize people um where would you like
your ashes scattered i want to be buried
so that i am consumed by the flora and
fauna of which i have dined upon for my
entire life for my sustenance so they
can return my body to the earth
no you had that prepared
and you want that honestly
do you want that written on the
gravestone as well because we might need
a pretty big gravestone for all of that
give me back to the earth okay
so i don't like azure scattered anywhere
yeah
there it is um when i think of
environments and stability and
access points there are also these sort
of magic places in a two body orbiting
system of the lagrange points where the
net sort of force of gravity and
centrifugal forces balance out and we
put the james webb space telescope in
one of those
orbits uh it's the earth sun l2 point so
it's like a million miles
opposite the direction of the sun and
when you put a satellite there it kind
of hangs out without requiring much
uh sustaining uh much in the matter of
fuel to sustain so it's a balance point
and so
are is this a factor in any of this
conversation about sustainability at all
because they're kind of magic points in
space i mean i'd like to know maybe they
can be exploited in some clever way
i think it's both a strength and
weaknesses one question is are we going
to end up seeing a lot of popularity in
those sites probably so i think it's
going to make sense as people are asking
what ways do you want to sort of have
systems working on the moon ask your
question how do you have logistics to
make sure you can provide facilities and
one could be to have some facilities you
know operating around launch points and
the question is how do we share them
right because any other place is just
unstable and we'll fall in or have to
orbit and track it track where it is so
i bet they're going to be very
attractive going forward in the future
yeah and because of that they should be
seen as a finite resource and they
should be thought about sustainably and
how we can operate in them then
sustainably like for sure they should be
seen as finite in my opinion
okay and so they're multiple but so
there's lagrangian points there's earth
moon crouching points there are five of
them and earth sun lagrangian points so
anything that orbits
uh you can find these five spots
and they're very cool and they can even
collect debris so for example the sun
jupiter lagrange points
right there are places in front of
jupiter and behind it in its orbit which
are two of the lagrange points they have
just
collected
meteors
so you look behind jupiter in front of
it to those and there's like trailing
meteors just hanging out there because
all the forces
enable that yeah and so it's been
suggested that in one of these places
you just put all of your engineering
materials you want to build something
just leave it there it's like your
storage closet because it's not going to
fall to any place else and then later on
you bring in all the assemblers and they
put it together so then maybe this
should be considered you're the moon
person put that on your i'm not a son
jeep is a person though
but no i think i think that makes sense
and um you know that i think it's all
about also transferring lessons learned
right so as we learn to work
um in an environment which is heavily
cluttered in leo and how we kind of
navigate away from debris that that
technology that thinking can be used to
if we do want to operate in these
lagrange points with lots of meteorites
how to navigate that field so really
it's just about bridging the lessons
learned in space and a lot of different
fronts okay
so something we haven't directly
addressed because we've been speaking of
satellites that were on purpose put
there and maybe then lived out their
useful life so
what about debris
the fact that three satellites last i
checked have been destroyed in orbit
by different countries china i think did
it first we did it second and russia i
think did it recently and
this
uh as a demonstration perhaps
but in any case
it's
it is itself
polluting the environment
making
all
activities
dangerous
so
i'm just wondering
what uh what solution do you have to
clean up the debris
there's three sentences what are you
going to do
well first i'll just say that uh
countries need to commit to no more
anti-satellite tests that's just needed
we need to have that be a global sense
of peer pressure across all countries uh
that's a geopolitical solution on the
engineering side it is exciting that
we're seeing capabilities got folks in
the room who are working directly on
missions and to do different forms we'll
just be clear the anti-satellite test
that's euphemism for let me blow my
satellite into a zillion pieces well
said we should clarify what we mean so
these are tests where country a says i'm
going to vote my own satellite to prove
that if i needed to i could blow up
yours but i can do that right now
they don't say that they don't say we're
going to walk our own satellite just to
see if we can do it
but i want you to watch as we do that
yes yeah you better be paying attention
yeah yeah
i mean it's yeah it seems like a very
childish thing to do
as a sort of threat it's like i'm just
gonna punch myself in the face
and i hope you guys are paying attention
because i could punch you in the face
too but my face is gonna be too sore for
me to do that we're gonna have to use
the money to re you know fix my face
yeah i don't know i don't know if that
really works but there's a difference
between knocking out a satellite in the
low earth orbit and in a higher earth
orbit right
so what's that i mean but don't all the
particles just fall back out and burn up
i mean i think you should ask them okay
yeah yeah don't pick it
again depends on some physics we got to
see uh altitude and we also want to ask
you know how popular the altitude is
where the original satellite was right
and what else is between the original
satellite and all the pieces it needs to
come down past i saw the movie gravity
oh okay i'm sorry
zero gravity because it was all in zero
gravity but in that movie they showed
this catastrophic failure of all
satellites because one satellite was
blown to bits and each of those bits
moving at 18 000 miles an hour
sorry i'm american what's that in
oh no miles were in the uk
18 000 uh miles an hour these are now
debris moving at 18 000 miles an hour
they can take out other satellites and
in that film if you haven't seen it it
would be gravity you got to get out by
the way if you haven't
a total satellite
uh collapse of the entire system and
which was uh was named after somebody um
the kessler effect i think yeah so
i just have to note that the huffle is
not the same altitude as the
international space station for those
who pay attention yeah yeah so she yeah
yeah so sandra bullock her character
she just decides to go
fix the hubble telescope
yeah but they're like hundreds of miles
apart in
altitude plus she's a medical doctor so
i wanted to keep her hands off my
telescope
as a natural physicist i don't bust into
her operating with my head
open heart surgery i got this i'm gonna
ask you a question right now
no i think that we had a good message
but maybe you know some of the physics
was uh simplified but the point of
course is that you know we do want to
ask you how other palettes are affected
by the breakup of one satellite and i'm
just asking what do you do about the
debris you all don't have those
solutions yet yeah oh no you guys matt's
got a solution no i'm gonna have to
bring up another movie right now
one of the the best and most atrocious
movies you will ever see is about
satellites in space trying to solve
climate change it's called geostorm
storm and okay but the lead actor was
from scotland yeah
just to be clear
the lead actress from scotland and so is
matt
so he might be a little biased here well
he lives in los angeles and his house
burned down due to fires in los angeles
and he still lives there and doesn't
live in our hometown anymore because
it's better to live somewhere that's on
fire than where i come from
where i'm from uh paisley just outside
of moscow just outside glasgow it was it
went up for the uk city of culture 2020
and lost to coventry
um which gets a laugh in the room it's
the equivalent of going up for an
academy award and losing to gerard
butler
some butler fans in today the point is
one draw yeah
okay
um it's about he he invents uh a
satellite that controls the climate and
it fixes climate change and then some
terrorists hijack that satellite yeah
and start messing with the climate and
there's
storms and stuff and the only guy that
can solve it is gerard butler he goes
into space turns out it was the uh vice
president
that controlled it so i've given away
the spoilers there but the point is one
of the greatest films of all time and
really don't spend your time watching it
is geostorm it's about satellites
climate change you know
interesting so this is a
a
uh that's not a let's clean things up
solution let's let us
fix things
up with what we call geo engineering
geoengineering exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah which
again i mean we're not gonna get
agreement when i joke about this you
know we have acid rain and so here's the
solution let's give everyone acid rain
proof umbrellas you know is that really
the solution
to fixing the acid rain problem i mean
some people would say yes people that
sell acid that invent acid rain proof
umbrellas would be like yeah we've got a
solution here for you guys so we should
go back to the question we were talking
about which is you know do we reduce
space debris by like creating less
debris or by trying to clean up the
debris that's already there i think we
need to do both and some of the ideas
people have for cleaning the roots there
are to send another satellite that can
hopefully go grab it whether it's you
know through a hook or through a
forceful docking so i think one question
i have is as we build new satellites can
we design them to be serviced so they
can actually be better right so if i set
up a satellite that can sweep up debris
i can set a satellite to sweep up your
satellite yeah it is a question that uh
another geopolitical question it's like
balls it's like you're trying to knock
the other ball out of the
thing do you have that game in the u.s
balls even like oh you mean batty bar is
bocce ball what is that
yeah exactly
new olympic sport
um so
so like we're gonna
slowly land this plane that we're flying
right now but let me get some sort of uh
reflections on this
uh what have we learned so far
that we can take as a
as a
as a bit of wisdom
i don't i don't even call it advice just
a bit of wisdom going forward
for all parties at the table what should
we be doing
so i think for
for me you know being in a company
that's sending things to the moon and as
danielle rightly mentioned we shouldn't
be dumping things um
the fact that
if i worked on a terrestrial company i
would know what regulations i operate
under a terrestrial company
you have to say
so if i work for a terrestrial company
everyone today works in a terrestrial
country
well if you go into the yeah if you
enter the moon on space and i would say
no you're going to you're working for a
space company
yeah sorry no all good um so i
if i work for a terrestrial camp every
time i say that now i'm going to think
of you um if i wait for a terrestrial
company i would know what regulations i
need to operate under
um what assessments i need to do to make
sure i'm compliant go find my handbook
make sure whatever whatever by the way
all of those compliances
are written we've got lawyers we're
written because something went wrong
yeah every line in a contract
in a document
was not known prior to the problem that
caused the line to be written in the
first place this is it for the moon we
know that we need to be delicate we know
that so we need to
as i'm in business development people
approach me saying i want to take this
payload to the moon i have no assessment
i have nothing i can pick up and be like
hey this is gonna should we shouldn't we
this is the this is the analysis this is
nothing no regulations that are very
translatable to the day-to-day for me
the best thing we can do
is normalize that bring that in and it's
very unusual for a company wanting to be
regulated
but it needs to be because we have we
should have responsibility and
accountability for what we send up there
satellite design that said when this
runs its useful life we have fuel to
de-orbit it or for it to self-destruct
or disappear or whatever is the magic
future physics that could affect the
health of the satellite yeah and tell me
about this eagle document you
co-authored what is that yeah so um as
part of this base generation advisory
council
led by antonino salmeri which is a space
lawyer actually sat there
um so it was meant to put together a
perspective on lunar governance from the
younger generation so right now lunar
governance is very fragmented
we saw that we went and spoke to lots of
different actors playing in the industry
that has a view
and we try to put together the young
person's perspective on what we what we
want to see in the world and that is the
output of that was a lunar governance
charter building upon the outer space
treaty so we're not trying to recreate
the wheel we're trying to build into
something implementable the outer space
treaty if you haven't read it it's an
interesting document from 1967 somewhere
around yeah this is it i can't pick it
up and know what to do from the outer
space treaty in my day-to-day job
yeah yeah so i'd recommend you read it
it's just a fascinating attempt to think
about the future realizing that space
was being born
in that decade yeah and it's four states
um public sector so private needs its
own its own thing
yeah so
just give me some some reflective
thoughts about where we should go in the
future i'm really excited to announce
that at this conference we are opening
up and launching tomorrow uh an
important initiative called the space
sustainability rating wait who's we we
is a group of organizations that come
together consortium led by the world
economic forum including mit ut austin a
company called bryce tech the european
space agency and we're really excited to
have at the epl space center epf alpha
space center which is in switzerland
what does epl stand for epfl is if i can
do my french
and french okay my french isn't great
but it's the uh
technique
anybody can
all right not too bad all right i got
nothing but very good and in english
should just be you know it's definitely
university in the sun but they are going
to lead this initiative with the support
of our design team we actually do have
specifically for low earth orbit and for
earth orbit in general a set of
guidelines which are the actions that
any space operator can take and help
reduce space to recreation and help
avoid collisions and so it's a long list
of options uh for the design phase the
operations phase and the end of life for
practices that can help and we're asking
companies to voluntarily get rated to
pay to get rated and to announce their
reign to the world to say how close they
are to matching these ideal practices
this is like the leads rating on a
building definitely
and even though it's it's it was just
the
government didn't require this it
becomes a sort of a voluntary thing and
then the public is trained to look for
that
for
buildings they might move their business
into or even just live in you can walk
into a building and say this you know
owner of this building chose to pay a
little extra money to have you know the
green practices for earth and so now
since we're not terrestrial company
we're asking for companies and do the
same thing both companies and
governments can get raided but i can say
this every leeds building i've been in
i've noticed that the air smells clean
in it and that makes me wonder what the
hell am i breathing in the other
building
and now you'll notice that your
satellite data smells cleaner because
it's going to come from
ssr rated emissions so man
you want satellites to help you monitor
what's happening on earth so you are
their enemy
yeah we want satellites but we just want
you to also yeah just clean up your
satellites after yourselves when you
possibly can but we need it we we need
so satellites look at greenhouse gas
emissions which you know methane
emissions we can now look at what's
happening across the entire world and a
bunch of oil and gas companies are
leaking methane here and there we can
spot that we can look at you know what
what's happening in neurosatellites so
methane is scottish for methane
it's like you had some new element name
yeah yeah
we're going to talk about aluminum in a
minute aluminium
let's not let it get let's not get into
it um
so
it's incredibly important one reason is
that the methane is uh
a short-lived greenhouse gas do you say
the word gas yeah cool i mean you
actually call what you put in your car's
gas which is nonsense because it's a
liquid anyway
you should have thought of that
shouldn't you um
so
yeah we look methane is a short-lived
with gas so actually you know um co2 is
sort of the main gas that we met that's
causing climate change methane causes
more in the short term
it's short-lived because it's highly
reactive right with other things in the
environment whereas co2 is a pretty
stable molecule correct chemistry of
that yeah yeah so some people think we
need to focus more on co2 others think
we need to focus more on methane but you
know the gas is always greener on the
other side
okay so
that's one of the worst jokes you'll
ever hear about climate change but very
accurate yeah and totally accurate but
you you still want your satellite data
but you're with everyone we're not gonna
believe we're gonna stop launching
satellites we just have to manage that
going forward exactly
in a way that we can all yeah
it's helping there you know more
satellites are helping the earth but
yeah as we you know we need to be
forward thinking about what are the
issues going to be caused in space
because of it
so and so i just want to say thank you
pamela for those
observations i want to share with you
what i've called a cosmic perspective on
all this
it's not
a new problem that
technology
engineering
forces operate on civilization in ways
that make life better
and we only later learn
what kinds of
constrictions in its place on our health
our wealth our
security
and all of those matter in space of
course
so
i'd rather view this not as a not as
some dire
problem but as a natural
course of evolution of what happens when
you become
better at something that you ever met
than you ever imagined
and so now you deal with it and i'm
delighted to see and learn
that not only is such a conference as
this
something that's happening now not in 10
years imagine if this conference were
held
50 years ago
when we first started
using plastic
in major ways for containers for food
containers and other applications just
imagine because if the tights plastic
use it once throw it away
where does it go no one thought about
that
okay it works its way into the oceans
okay
and now last i've read the fish we eat
are 50 plastic isn't that correct man
i think it's something like that there's
now i think something around twice the
weight of all of the animals on the
earth in plastic in plastic is in the
ocean uh i just
accumulated total we have sort of like
twice the entire weight of all mammals
or something yeah okay
and another data i'm just informed by my
crack team of researchers that the
weight of a credit card's worth of
plastic that might be found in larger
fish that are fished on the ocean so
no one was thinking this
at the dawn of that era
but the fact that that did happen that
way
i think has informed how responsible we
need to be going forward now
and so in that way it's a silver lining
to our short-sightedness of the past
but it's only a silver lining if in fact
we can look to the past and learn from
it
so that our descendants can be proud of
what we have bequeathed them rather than
embarrassed by what we have left
that's a cosmic perspective for this
sustainability conference thank you all
for
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
you